the first trailer for spider-man far
from home was pretty amazing and
spectacular but it was also stuffed with
more MCU and Marvel Comics tidbits than
you can shake a spider stick at here are
even more small details you may have
missed in the far from home trailer as
excited as they are for all things MCU
plenty of fans are still kind of annoyed
that far from homes trailer has revealed
that so many characters are alive before
we get to see what happens in the fight
against Thanos and the Avengers end game
well whatever dude the trailer reveals
that Cobie Smulders is back in the role
of Nick Fury's number 2 Maria hill what
will she be up to in spider-man's side
of the MCU probably fighting Giants and
monsters for starters at the very least
we know that whatever the Avengers do to
win the day and endgame Hill has been
undusted right along with Nick Fury and
Spidey himself one encouraging detail in
the far from home trailer happens before
Peter leaves New York City before
heading out on his trip he pays a visit
to the new bodega location of the
friendly mr. Delmar whose original store
he inadvertently helped destroy while
thwarting a high-tech ATM robbery and
homecoming DOMA
while he's still the same kindly
neighborhood grocer we saw he was in the
first movie Delmar clearly hasn't
forgotten about the violent destruction
of his original store and for whatever
reason he doesn't want his customers to
forget either up above the register he
saved some framed newspapers with
headlines and photos about the incident
including a framed photo of him doing go
web go hands next to spider-man not a
bad souvenir while out sightseeing in
London the students faced an attack
while in traffic on the Tower Bridge as
lightning strikes all around them Peters
classmates sprint between buses and cars
to find safety as they do we can see a
license plate on a bus that partially
reads mys which certainly seems like it
refers to the movies probable villain
Mysterio on the back of a nice shiny
Audi another license plate reads 2865
SCP now remember the ASM 2:12 we spotted
in Venice which likely pointed to Hydra
man's first appearance an amazing
spider-man number 212 well this license
plate seems the reference another
villains first appearance specifically
September 1965 s amazing spider-man
number 28 the debut appearance of the
Spidey villain molten man who we seemed
to have glimpsed at a different point in
the trailer think we're done with the
secret license plate messages think
again when the giant sand monster rises
up to fight Nick Fury and Maria hill we
can see the first three digits of yet
another car's license plate the visible
portion of the plate reads 463 that
seems the reference amazing spider-man
number 4 published in September 1963 and
which featured the introduction of the
classic Spidey character Sandman we've
seen Sandman in the movies before he
appeared is one of several bad guys in
spider-man 3 played by Thomas Haden
Church how will this version of Spidey
sandy scoundrel differ from the one
we've seen before we'll know for sure on
July 15 up with the license plates right
spider-man far from home manages yet
another stylish shout out in its first
trailer this time specifically for
classic Spidey writer JM DeMatteis
who gets a hotel in Venice named after
him for those who don't know D Mateus
worked with most of the major comic book
companies including writing over 300
issues with Marvel Comics alone he's
responsible for writing some or all of
the most significant spider-man stories
including maximum carnage a Harry Osborn
Green Goblin centric the child within
and perhaps most notably Cravens last
during the opening scenes of the US
version of the far from home trailer
Peter watches as happy Hogan and Aunt
May awkwardly flirt with each other nice
thank you you too
thank you any dresses yes it is hot you
know what just happened what seems to
have just happened is that happy and May
might already be dating at this point in
the movie story having kept the whole
thing something of a secret from Peter
up until now the line of dialogue that
really sets off sirens for the potential
plot development is when happy
complements May's new dress but won't
say how he knows its new in front of
Peter it feels like the only way for him
to know the details of Mays wardrobe
would be if they were spending a lot of
time together socially without Peter
knowing in the past Tony Stark was
always the flirty one when it came to
Aunt May it's so hard for me to believe
that she's someone's am yeah
we come in all shapes and sizes you know
this woman date loaf is exceptions you
stop you there but as it turns out MAME
might have been single and looking
looking past Tony and apparently right
at the guy who does all of Starks grunt
work if true good going dude I have to
tell you not a fan of that Tony Stark
well the students are resting up at
their hotel after Mysterio steps in to
say Venice you can see a small sticker
on the lid of Ned's laptop featuring a
picture from a popular web comic that
you may remember going viral in 2016 in
case you don't recognize the small
sticker it's the this is fine dog from a
widely shared installment in the series
gun show by artist Casey green the comic
which is basically about being oblivious
and cheerful while your house burns down
around you also embraces a philosophy
that we feel would really come in handy
if we lived in the constantly besieged
world of the MCU
despite all the frequent disasters and
threats of annihilation it still manages
to seem like a pretty fun place to live
Dark Elves want to dominate the nine
realms this is fine Scarlet Witch blew
up a building sparking several
international incidents this is fine the
far from home trailer kind of sort of
spoiled some parts of Avengers endgame
that's well that's not ideal but it's
fine check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about spider-man and the MCU are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]
you